okay next game we have this weasel from
Canada yeah we got some position from
some salt off I'm not sure what it is
called actually some old Indian hybrid
whatever heck no idea what what this is
called and I don't have a really decent
knowledge here the salt setups supposed
to be on quite okay for black but I
don't really know how it is played at
some point on why it suddenly wants to
go for for f3
not sure how to react on that one basic
issue always is the night coming to be
six at some point what about v5 here on
fe 4 then be for the night retreats and
then I take on e4 with the night here no
idea looks active though maybe it can
even know at some point try to to win
the poor 95 there should be seven as
well ok but don't have a4 a5 here what
does he respond now
taking before can't really okay but this
looks some a bit a bit loose i would say
not sure what to make of this
yeah maybe I should just take here now
this isn't an idea to to get this one to
c5 Bishop to f6 maybe I don't think it's
really issue that be five is someone
always a bishop a six at the end and
also a to some hanging as well yeah
maybe maybe this no okay no nights you
find perhaps
yeah really complicated position I don't
think I have any particular problems but
it's also not at all easy to play of
course so we take this one off and go
rook e8
no Queen g5 in order to allow
recapturing on the edge with the rook
always need to pay attention to 96cm and
just as I'm talking about it is playing
it
the end this is some really unpleasant
yeah maybe it's not not that much of a
problem but it turn allows him to to go
f4 and then your future and open up the
bishop which was always his problem
peace may be a four-time morning yeah I
really need to play quicker a 42 to keep
the bishop in of course he's got this
move now but i have the square for the
Queen
and didn't take their
yeah I have to really play play quicker
takes on be 55 got 94
yeah this is a matter of of the of the
active night [ __ ] am I'm able to really
get some some play here
I need to to break the pin
luckily I got some some tricks working
for me you had a maid threat
check
rookie three is coming
check check check check white for fins
on time yeah no idea it looked critical
at some point but then he really started
to waste lots of time on not especially
good moves yeah I guess quite a lucky
victory